So, here’s me with a 65cm tube down my nose
draining my stomach fluids.
Not awesome.
Long story short, I got in a car crash, had
stomach surgery, and now scar tissue in my
abdomen means I have to pay attention to my
bowels a lot more than the average person.
But, a lifetime of having doctors inspecting
my digestive tract has taught me just how
important it is to take half a second and
check the toilet after you poo.
You should do it.
It’s weird, but trust me, it’s fascinating.
On average, good stool from a healthy body
should come once a day and be brown, smelly,
and smooth.
But you might not be average, so important
to know what YOUR normal is!
And you can’t know what that is without
taking a peep at your poop.
This is a real chart doctor’s developed
the classify stool.
You want to be somewhere in this range, an
indication you’re eating enough fiber and
you’re properly hydrated.
Getting on this end of the spectrum, you’re
likely constipated, and on this end, you might
be eating more fat than your liver and gallbladder
can process.
Basically, you want your stool to mimic the
shape of a healthy intestine.
Beyond shape, what your poo does in the toilet
is also important.
You generally want sinkers, not floaters.
*pause*
Floaters might be a sign you’re eating too
much fat or that there’s a lot of gas in
your gut.
Poop tends to have high fat content because
your body isn’t absorbing nutrients properly,
or it could mean that you have a lot of gas
building up in your gut and need to eat differently.
Colour is important, too.
Poo is brown because of bile, a product of
the liver that’s vital for digestion, but
it can be other colours.
Green might mean you have a fast digestive
system and eat a lot of leafy vegetables,
and red *could* mean you had beets not too
long ago, but could also be an indicator of
blood from a tear in the colon.
If it’s red and you haven’t eaten a bit
of nature’s candy -- talk to your doctor.
Stool can also come in black; if you’re
seeing a lot of that, it’s also time to
go to the doctor.
Same with light poos; it could be symptomatic
of a block in bile flow or liver disease.
But again, know your normal, because an irregular
poo from time to time is fine.
It’s really the long-term changes you need
to worry about.
There’s a super simple test you can do to
figure out your own system.
Add corn to any meal and log the time you
eat it.
Then all you have to do is wait.
Your body can’t digest the fibrous outer
shell of the corn kernels, so you’ll see
them!
Don’t freak out, just make a note of the
time!
That’s how long it takes your body to digest
and make waste!
Doing two or three rounds of this mini-experiment
would get you an average time it takes for
your body to digest a meal.
At that point you’ll be able to match any
irregular stool to the food that maybe doesn’t
totally agree with you.
Because don’t we all just want to feel great
in our bodies all the time?
So after all this, talking about stool is
still kinda taboo, so if you’re looking
for a more palatable dinner topic, check out
this video about the family tree astronomers
have made for the stars in our galaxy.
So.
Honesty time.
Do you pay attention to your digestion?
Let us know in the comments, don’t forget
to like this video, and be sure to subscribe
for new episodes of Seeker.